hello everyone and welcome to game
number nine of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between a charlatan
ireland and magnus carlsen before we
check out this very nice game we do have
a nice photo challenge congratulations
to everyone from the previous photo
challenges of course it was Boris
Gelfand but for this one it will be
extremely difficult as this photo is
extremely rare and I don't think a lot
of you may not may never have seen it so
best of luck to everyone who is the the
young boy here playing the black pieces
so best of luck once again to everyone
and now let's check out the dis game
like we said this game 9 from the World
Chess Championship match so far if
you've seen the previous eight videos
first four games were drawn Dan Carson -
won two games in a row and then another
two games were drawn so now crossing
under definitely needs a win he has the
white pieces and this game he will try a
different approach you will no longer go
for afor and face the Berlin and run
into a wall rather he will go for d4 and
we will have a nice nimzo-indian game so
definitely definitely a different
approach as you know if it doesn't work
you know don't don't repeat it like
Kasparov did against chronic and as he
bashed the Berlin over and over and over
so in this game Anand opens it with d4
as we've said we have a knight to f6 c4
and a 6 so we have nice to see 3 and now
Bishop to b4 the name is o Indian
defense and f3 and already here this is
the more variation you can see a nice
tweet by onigiri
he says a good start for the fans of
wish f3 is an unlucky move
so we have D 5 a 3 butter up captures
and c3b captures on c3 and now C 5 C
captures on d5 and now he captures on d5
transposing into the famous position of
the kappa blanka versus both winning
game
we have III and here Carlsen pushes C
for something good you will not see very
often locking down the
inside like this and allowing black
allowing whites to put to push for
advantage on the kingside but also to
gain a great advantage in the center
more usual would be something like
castling and then after Bishop to d3 be
692 Bishop to a6 and the white will
castle but what it will be always be
easier for whites to play this position
here Carson plays c4 and it's important
to say that semen Agostini was call
since previous coach and he was he was
not known to play this c4 move so
probably what a white Carson is prepared
for it we have 92 Knights the c6 and now
g4 and now as Carson closed the position
on the Queen side is ready to expand on
the King side this night is coming to g3
later maybe it will come to h5 maybe to
have f5 who knows definitely a nice
position but here Nigel short ruins it
for everyone as he posts this very nice
tweet black is about three Tempe up on
the Guru Fischer game from Havana 1966
but that shouldn't worry wish it too
much so official basically already had
this position with the black pieces only
cross and has the same position being up
as short says about 310 P so not a bad
position for black so we have castles by
Carlsen Bishop to G - nice - a five and
here we have castles Knight to b3
attacking the rook rook to a2 by Anand
and now b5 cost and immediately expands
on the Queen side it's interesting that
the strongest idea here is actually h6
but h6 as strong as it is
I was already played unit polgár played
h6 against Garry Kasparov in 1977 in
Tilburg and after night the g3 Bishop to
d7 Queen to e1 rook to e8 Kasparov
sacrificed a pawn with E 4 and after he
captures F captures and polgár capturing
on g4 cuz para was down upon but
eventually as part of managed to win the
game so it's hard to say of course and
knew about this so that's why he avoided
h6 or he just found
that'd be five who was better for some
reason well okay regardless night to g3
by and we have a five g5 and night the
e8e for night captors and c1 queen
captors and c1 and now rope to a6
Carlson decided to part with this strong
night and captured the bishop on c1
because he didn't want this bishop to
come to III then remand would sorry
about that
Alan would keep the bishop pair and he
would have a very nice position this way
across and eliminates the threat of the
bishop pair and at some point he will be
ready to put b4 and create a nice past
point on the condo Queen side and pushes
with E 5 we have night to see 790 c7 a
wild move as a cousin completely leaves
the King side he's now completely ready
to push on the Queen side and he says
that Island does not have enough
pressure on the Kings side but aren't
things differently he pushes f4 we have
before and here aren't plays a capture
some before he should have completely
disregarded this b4 idea by Carlson and
continued with his attack which would
have five and then after b3 rook a to F
to double up on the F file and then push
for advantage here on undecided to
exchange a pair of rooks we have phone
captures pawn captures rook captures and
Knight captures and now not worrying
about this pawn as you know if you
capture this one then this becomes a
passed pawn so no reason to do something
like this
errant continues with the attack he
pushes f5 we have b3 by Carlson and here
Queen to f4 Queen to f4 aren't really
spent a lot of time on this move as
there are so many things to calculate of
course the the ideal position you want
to find yourself in is f6 if black
prevents this then Queen h6 a Queen
Queen h4 Queen to h6 and then maybe
threaten some Queen g7 ideas so Carson
definitely has to bring the knight back
into the defense under - push f6 and
here cost and pushes g6 and the g6 to be
able to play this you really have to
calculate that white will not be able to
checkmate you with with this as Carson
could have played G captures on f6 but
for some reason he decided that he
doesn't have to
because after night h5 we have captures
and now after this check King King will
move and now after pink afters a black
will have sufficient country plywood
rock to g8
now you can't capture with the night
because the Queen is hanging and after
Queen captures Queen captures night
chapters and in captures and would be
out the exchange but the past be pond
will eventually win the game
so after this f6 move across in place g6
and he will now prove that the white is
white is indeed unable to checkmate the
black King we have Queen to h4 nice to
eat it now defending the g7 square and
now current and could go for 92
immediately and perhaps he should have
after b2 and 94 piling up on the d5 pawn
Queen to a5 going for c3 and also Queen
to a one knife characters on b5 is
coming and then after Bishop to e6 it
would be a really doubled edge position
but white would definitely have chance
this year instead after this night we
move on and has a different plan he
plays Queen to h6 we have b2 by Carlson
and here now if you play Knight to e2
with the same idea of night f4 now Queen
a5 is coming and after Knight to f4
Bishop blocks with Bishop to e6 Knight
captures pawn captures and now after
Bishop to h3 threatening Bishop captures
here now Queen to a6 will defend the
pawn here and after rook to be one rope
to f7 now blogs the pawn and completely
defense
you cannot capture the pawn as Queen to
a queen to a1 check will window rook so
black would defend this position and all
would be well so here after this B to
move across an island plays what is
considered to be the greatest move of
this of this world chess championship
match here island plays rook to f4
a great rook lift that allows cousin to
bring another Queen into the game cousin
does play this move as there is no other
move that would even allow black to play
this game so we have point to be one
promoting to a queen and now you have to
figure out how to defend this the white
king is in check so there are a couple
of ways you can
prevent this check you can go King to f2
although that's really not gonna do you
any good as you do have to win this game
rook to f1 doesn't really make all that
much sense because White's plan is now
rook to h4 and queen to h7 checkmate
so if white can get out of checks then
this checkmate will not be cousin will
not be able to avoid this checkmate
let's see what happens if you block with
Bishop to d1 if you block with Bishop to
d1 then Queen to d1 is the only defense
rock to h4 and now Queen to h5 this is
the only maneuver you have and after
Knight captures pawn captures rook
captures now Queen to h7 will be
checkmate but cousin can't defend with
Bishop to f5 and now the move you have
to find to go for Bishop to d1 and
Bishop to f1 idea is g6 only move that
saves black is Bishop captures and then
a rope to g5 will pin the bishop and h4
h5 is now coming black can't move any of
the pieces Knight captures on f6 will
have to happen at some point so black
will have to give up his extra material
and then it's hard to say if white can
actually pull this for a win but
definitely the best choice for Anand
after this Queen b1 check upon 2 b1
promoting to Queen check would have been
better to f1 but Allen finds an even
better idea and he plays Knight to f1
now his idea is that a queen to D 1
followed by root 2 H 4
Queen to h5 and now he wants it to play
rook captures on h5 and after pawn
captures now go 93 and now white is
simply winning because now there's a
threat against this pawn Knight captures
in 97 will win the game so you do have
to block this but now a bunch of
characters comes and you cannot allow
Bishop captures Bishop so here you would
either have to give up the Queen and
then you lose the game or you play
Bishop captures and now comes Knight to
f5 and now there is nothing you can do
here whatever you play 97 check is
coming and now you either move the King
and get checkmate it or instead you
could capture and then you're even gonna
lose this rook so after your blog
checkmate again you
lose this and f queen d6 black has no
compensation for the Queen
so after this night to f1 move on and
thought that he has his first victory in
the bag but unfortunately he missed one
move that cousin found so here's the
position I welcome you to pause the
video here and try to find the move that
completely crushes Islands idea so I
will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you've just made life extremely
difficult for Ireland and for those who
just want to enjoy the show here cousin
plate Queen e1 and now after on and saw
this horror
he simply resigned to the game
immediately unmoved 28th so yeah the
idea of Queen to e1 is now that the
knight is no longer on g6 when you
blocked with the bishop then the knight
was on g3 and Queen e1 made no sense but
now that Knight is here the Queen is
guarding h4 and now a rock edge 4 is
nothing simply Queen captures Queen
captures and now it's actually black
that can play anything there are no more
threats here black's pawn structure is
intact there was no G captures on h5
ruining black's pawn structure Knight is
covering g7 so you will never be able to
checkmate and after you defend something
let's say this and what black is up a
whole rook and it has a completely
winning position so after Queen to e1
the unfortunate moved a ton and missed
talent immediately resigned the game so
after nine run after nine games cousin
is now in the lead
6 to 3 and as the game the the match was
supposed to last 12 games so now for
Anand even continue playing this match
he has to win all three games in a row
to you know put the match into playoffs
into some rapid and blitz games so here
we have a photo from the press
conference after game 9 they asked Anand
what's his plan now there are no more
strategies left now he simply has to win
all three games in a row and of course
he responded that I'm definitely gonna
try and win three games in a row now
although it doesn't seem all that likely
well yeah that's the game I do hope
and are enjoying the coverage so far I
would like to thank Farah Dean genic
Jonathan Farrell Matthew home Steven
green and James Graham for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot -
really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I will make both of
them from this Watchers championship
series thank you for watching and I will
see you soon with another game from this
nice match so yeah thank you all and
I'll see you soon
and best of luck in the photo challenge